est ce qu'il ya des questions dans la
salle
oui merci oui bonjour monsieur bournazel
bonjour moi je suis prêt mais comment
dirais-je
il ya très longtemps que je me pose une
question sur le logement social
nous voyons par nous savons que le maire
de paris qui soit deux maires de droite
ou de gauche
l'appréhension enfin a le droit de
préempter des logements pour faire des
logements sociaux
donc là je suis bon et tout est long on
en voit partout dans tous les
arrondissements logements sociaux aux
conducteurs mairie de paris donc là
monsieur guardian viennent de nous dire
qu'il y en a pas beaucoup de construit
parce qu'il reste toujours autant de
demandes mais je crois que le problème
ce ticket en année c'est dans
l'attribution des logements dont
monsieur monsieur bon nazelle est ce
qu'on se rend compte bien de ces jeunes
couples qui habite la banlieue qui ont
des enfants qui doivent les réveiller au
plus tard à 7 heures du matin les
trimballer dans les transports en commun
pour les faire arriver sur les lieux a
connu de travail
bon enfin je passe sur la fatigue des
parents et en plus le manque
d'efficacité après pour le travail dans
donc monsieur mona zèle pourriez vous et
je sais que vous serez élu s il sera
possible de donner la priorité à ses
jeunes couples qui démarre dans la vie
avec des petits salaires avec des
enfants en bas âge pour arrêter de
d'être un ballet pendant deux heures le
matin et deux heures le soir parce que
nous avons un peu l'impression que ces
logements sont vus vous répondre les non
mais attendez je termine on a la
pression mais non ne pas nous dans le
secret des dieux que les logements
sociaux sont donnés en priorité du
désolé de ce que je vais dire à des
chômeurs dont on sait qu'ils ne
travailleront jamais voilà alors je vais
vous répondre
nous on veut pas opposer les catégories
les unes aux autres on veut simplement
remettre de l'équilibré
c'est à dire que le logement aidé doit
aller pour tout le monde viseur
s'il vous plaît d'abord vis-à-vis des
personnes les plus en difficulté c'est
normal c'est le devoir de solidarité
dans la république française mais aussi
vis-à-vis des classes moyennes qui sont
les grands oubliés
les grandes sacrifier la politique du
logement de la ville de paris la région
ile de france qui ne peuvent pas se
loger dans le logement privé et à qui on
ne propose jamais rien et nous nous
voulons réserver une part d attribution
de logements aux classes moyennes
notamment vous avez dit les jeunes
couples
les apprentis aussi les étudiants les
jeunes travailleurs mais aussi madame
pour les retraités parce que les
retraités
lorsque ils arrêtent de travailler
perdre du pouvoir d'achat et certaines
familles de retraités ne peuvent plus se
maintenir dans notre ville et dans notre
région
parce qu'en perdre du pouvoir d'achat
ils n'arrivent plus à vivre dans le
logement privé
donc nous ce que nous voulons c'est
reconstruire une chaîne dans la
politique du logement et trouver un
équilibre générationnel un équilibre
social et arrêter la logique du ghetto
l'action publique le financement du
logement doit profiter à tout le monde
notamment aux plus jeunes mais aussi aux
classes moyennes et de la même façon
nous voulons relancer l'accession
sociale à la propriété je lui ai dit
tout à l'heure pour permettre à des
hommes et à des femmes qui vivent de
leurs revenus du travail qui ont des
revenus modestes de pouvoir devenir
propriétaire car c'est cela le mérite et
l'ascenseur social aujourd'hui à paris
en ile de france à paris en tout cas on
ne fait plus un seul programme la
section sociale à la propriété dont vous
le voyez nous sommes sur la même
longueur d'onde et avec valérie pécresse
c'est ce volontarisme là cet équilibre
là en matière de logement que nous
voulons porter et faire en sorte que la
ville de paris comme la région
ile-de-france soit accessible à toutes
les catégories sociales est pas réservé
à quelques unes il faut mettre fin à
cette logique qui a malheureusement créé
de grosses difficultés dans un nombre de
quartiers de l'île de france
d'autres questions monsieur oui bonjour
jean luc gauthier je suis militant de
base merci tout d'abord pour
l'organisation de cette matinée qui est
vraiment très très bien fait
je travaille dans l'immobilier et je
fais un constat régulièrement c'est que
lorsqu'on superpose la carte des
résultats des dernières élections
électorales avec la carte des quartiers
où le droit de préhension et renforcé il
ya une parfaite similitude c'est à dire
que partout où la droite est encore
présente
on essaie de présenter pour mettre des
logements sociaux et donc pour je suis
un peu inquiet pour pour l'avenir c'est
que l'on va mettre effectivement des
logements sociaux dans pas mal de
quartier encore et d'autre part une
autre remarque est également c'est que
savez-vous qu'il ya eu un immeuble rue
de châteaudun qui a été présentée c'est
un immeuble de bureaux qui a été à
présenter à un certain prix et le prix
de revient total de cet immeuble a été
de 12000 euros du mètre carré est
aujourd'hui celle où est à 7 euros le
mètre carré
voilà merci monsieur ça corroborent ce
que nous disions tout à l'heure la
politique de préemption qui est mise en
place par la ville de paris c'est simple
la ville de paris et achète avec votre
argent notre argent l'argent du
contribuable un logement dans un
immeuble privé on chasse souvent la
population qui est dans cet appartement
dans cet immeuble et on la remplace par
une note
on n'a pas créé un nouveau logement on a
simplement changé un logement de
catégorie qui est passé d'un logement
privé un logement social
c'est la logique du chiffre et ça ça
aurait pour conséquence de faire
augmenter les prix évidemment du marché
est de saturer un peu plus le marché
parisien
finalement madame hidalgo je veux pas
dire est devenu le roi mais l'arrêt du
bus de la spéculation immobilière sa
politique renforce la spéculation
immobilière chasse les classes moyennes
et les familles de paris et crée en
paris ii
deux catégories les plus aisées comme on
dit depuis très longtemps et de plus est
des plus aidés et au fond on a plus de
classe moyenne qui font pourtant vivre
nos quartiers les commerces de proximité
la diversité sociale dans nos crèches et
dans nos écoles et c'est ce à quoi on
veut mettre fin avec valérie pécresse à
la région ile de france
monsieur lecoq à une question ou une
remarque le maire du 6e arrondissement
sur et de romain je vais dire que
t'étais un excellent candidat et que tu
allais porter nos couleurs
là c'est tout je n'avais pas prévu un
excusez moi une question madame modeste
m'adore à propos du logement social moi
je j'ai entendu ce qu'a dit madame et je
les dis à valérie pécresse ont dit on
dit des choses on dit des choses qui
sont variables d'un endroit à un autre
en ce qui concerne les commissions
d'attribution ont dit on les donne aux
et résiste c'est faux on dit on les
donne aux chômeurs c'est faux en réalité
ce qui se passe et j'ai un fils qu'il
attend depuis huit ans donc je connais
sur le terrain le cas ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il ya des commissions qui exige
un cdi pour donner un logement social
et il ya des commissions au contraire
qu'ils les donnent effectivement attendu
en droit aux gens au rsa aux chômeurs
etc
voilà donc les règles sont pas les mêmes
partout et je sais pas à quel niveau ça
se joue mais ça serait bien de faire en
sorte que les règles d'attribution soit
homogénéiser dans les diverses
commissions merci madame on retient
votre remarque est maintenant je crois
qu'il est l'heure d'accueillir nicolas
sarkozy